[Music]
scientists have been preparing for
decades for next week's total solar
eclipse but people living along its path
have just a few more days until their
communities are inundated with millions
of tourists the Eclipse begins in Oregon
on Monday morning it will need less than
two hours to reach South Carolina the
South Carolina State Museum in Columbia
is preparing for the big celebration
celebration so mark Strassmann is there
mark good morning good morning this is
one of America's top three most visited
public observatories and come Monday
this telescope will be pointed directly
at the Eclipse and live-streamed
everywhere on a typical day they get
between 300 and 500 visitors here on
Monday that'll be ten times that number
and crowd control will be an issue all
along the eclipses path you don't
usually see crowd control road blocks at
a museum but on Monday this Observatory
will be overrun by thousands of eclipse
fans coming to see the stars in the
middle of the day when temperatures are
expected to be in the 90s
we'll have band-aids we'll have
additional water seating we actually are
bringing in missing tents and fans as
well the Eclipse will travel almost
2,400 miles across the u.s. 12 million
people live in the totality zone of
complete darkness but 10 million
visitors are expected to squeeze their
way into the eclipses path with
populations expected to nearly double
cities and towns are redoubling their
efforts to get ready we're gonna run out
I'm sure we're gonna run out of stuff
this Idaho market is already seeing a
run on bottled water and other basic
supplies we're hoping we can get
shipments every day to keep up with the
demand that we're gonna have there's
gonna be a lot of people coming through
down while the Eclipse is 70 miles wide
many of the roads people are using to
see it are narrow just two lanes in some
rural areas my biggest concern is
emergency vehicle access with the folks
that we expect to come to this eclipse
we are really concerned about just
getting to our emergencies the Eclipse
will last only about two minutes but if
you're planning to see it you should
plan for a much longer visit the best
thing to do is give yourself plenty of
time enjoy it and then give yourself
time well after it's over as well so
many people hoping for their glimpse of
the Eclipse that South Carolina has put
its National Guard on standby in Oregon
they've taken a one step further and the
governor has already activated that
States National Guard Gale thank you
very much my where you gonna be I was
just gonna ask you that shall I go to
your house in Bellport oh well yes that
would be perfect please go over there
would you come see it would be great
Nora that's how we go we just invite
ourselves really enjoys that we need to
say bye you're all invited this show up
huh yes Charlie we'll be handing out his
number a little bit later in the
broadcast thank you very much mark but I
do want to say your partners get to